thought Howard she had some pretty
interesting tidbits about how Starfield
used to be a lot more punishing and it's
hard not to wish that some of these
things were still in the game apparently
enemy Ai and ship combat was
intentionally made very stupid in order
to make it more fun they also said that
ship combat and how planets would
function in general took a very very
long time to figure out and they said
that planets originally were much more
punishing in general it seems like
across the board there are a lot more
survival-like elements they did also
confirm that there are no tutorials on
purpose including for the base building
and shipbuilding in order to give
players the opportunity to just figure
things out for themselves they also said
the game was finished nine months ago in
order to allow time for polish and that
it is designed to be supported for many
years to come so I wonder what that
means I do definitely feel like it would
be a little bit more interesting if
ships had a bigger variety like
different kinds of ships you effectively
just fight the same thing at different
levels it would be much more interesting
I think if they took like a Star Wars
approach or you were fighting different
varieties of the same kind of ship